from Death frisbees to Nuke bracelets
these Predator weapons will make you say
yaocha Hunters never leave home without
a hunting knife even if it's just a
dress an animal after the kill just like
the Hunter's knife a predator never
disembarks his ship without a Nifty set
of wrist blades and these puppies are
definitely meant for up close and
personal encounters
[Music]
the original 1987 film every Predator
has done battle with a set of wrist
blades some predators have even taken
their wrist blades to the next level
like the one seen in the first Alien vs
Predator film these alien hunters
practically have swords attached to
their wrists in fact it's a wonder they
can even maneuver with wrist blades as
big as the one seen in AVP
as far as iconic Weaponry is concerned
wrist blades are a true staple of the
Predator's Arsenal they don't just maim
and kill they also help work just as
effectively in skinning the kill and
claiming a souvenir for the trophy wall
back in the predator ship in short never
get close to a predator actually you
don't want to be at a distance from them
either for other reasons that we'll get
into in just a moment basically if you
see a predator at any distance you can
kiss your butt goodbye
remember how we said you didn't want to
be at a distance from a predator well
this would be why it seems the creature
has ranged combat locked up nice and
tight with this part of its deadly
Arsenal the shoulder Cannon is an ultra
accurate firearm that targets and shoots
a deadly explosive or plasma-like blast
at the Predator's Target
prey appears to be the only film where a
shoulder Cannon isn't used as it likely
hasn't been invented by the time the
prequel takes place
however the original 1987 film shows
just how devastating the shoulder
cannons can be when Jesse Ventura's
Blaine has a hole punched clean through
the middle of his torso then Bill Duke's
Mac thinks he has the drop on the
creature just before the targeting
system zeroes in on him unfortunately
his head ends up getting popped like a
grape gross
mop it up it does not look like a fun
way to go
it feels like an ancient weapon but it's
one definitely fitting for an alien
species dead set on enjoying the thrill
of the hunt the spear has been used on
multiple occasions throughout Predator
history it is typically seen as a
shorter shaft before extending into a
full-length battle-ready spear so the
Predator can carry it around with ease
while the Predator didn't use the spear
in the original film The Weapon made its
memorable debut in 1990s predator 2. in
traditional Predator lore the spear is
referred to as a Combi stick but in
Alien vs Predator a spear makes a return
in a different form while a Combi stick
is initially used the Predator later
creates a spear out of a xenomorph tail
in prey the Predator actively uses a
spear-like weapon that is likely A
Primitive version of the combi stick
it appears to have two separate pieces
that can attach together to form a spear
or bladed staff but the two parts can be
separated and dual wielded at the
Predator's convenience one of the
Comanche Warriors in prey finds this out
the hard way as he's impaled against a
fallen tree with the spear it's a pretty
slick weapon that claims a lot of lives
what could be more practical as a
hunting device than a deadly frisbee
while Predators have constructed just
that for use during the hunt Okay so the
word frisbee might be a bit of an
oversimplification but it's hard to
ignore the resemblance the disc does
seem to have a layer of advanced
technology imbued in its design as it
can Target hostile forces and even
boomerangs back to its owner after doing
the deed
Predator 2 is the first time such a
weapon is seen in the movie franchise
playing a memorable role in the climax
in the ice cold Meat Locker near the end
of the film special agent Keys is
bisected in a grisly sequence in which
the predator outsmarts and nearly kills
the entire unit Lieutenant Mike Harrigan
later takes the disc for himself
ultimately slaying the Predator with its
own Weapon by manually plunging it into
the beast's torso
other iterations of the bladed disc have
been seen in cinematic Predator history
such as in the scene from the much
reviled Alien vs Predator Requiem in
which an overconfident teen girl runs
right into the device this time however
the disc pins her to the wall acting
more like a high-tech ninja star than a
self-returning bladed disc
in the remote jungles of Central America
Dutch and his mercenary crew embark on a
search and rescue operation this is the
basis for the 1987 film that started it
all these Commandos think they're well
aware of the danger they're in for
heavily fortified and armed hostile
units populate the jungle and surround
the target surely a gunfight will ensue
and there will be casualties but a third
party enters The Fray apparently
attracted by the unfolding conflict it
doesn't have allegiances and it most
certainly doesn't pick sides any armed
combatant is fair game in the great hunt
across all the hardened gun-toting
individuals walking the jungle Dutch
outlasts them all he has a bone to pick
with this alien Hunter who's seemingly
obliterated his entire team using his
wits he bests the predator in a game of
cat and mouse of course the Predator
won't go down quietly choking on its own
blood it activates a device on its
Gauntlet that appears to be a countdown
timer
[Laughter]
with his enemy denying him a Victory lap
Dutch has to Sprint for survival to
escape the Predator's self-destruct
strategy after detonating the explosive
appears to have the same effect as a
small tactical nuclear weapon it's a
devastating device that ensures the
Predator vaporizes not just his own
technology but any living thing in the
area this helps ensure that these aliens
remain nothing more and nothing less
than a mysterious Legend to any culture
that may have encountered them nearly
300 years before Dutch's encounter with
a predator the predator of the prey era
used explosive drones that emerged from
his Gauntlet and sought out hostile
targets it's a devastating One-Shot kill
sure to vaporize any life form contained
within its blast in prey the alien
Hunter employs the use of this weapon
during a fight with French fur Trappers
earlier in the film this band of
Ruffians had captured nauru and
attempted to squeeze information from
her about her encounter with the Beast
refusing to Aid their cause she and her
brother are strapped to a tree and used
as bait for the otherworldly Hunter
instead the hunter pursues the fur
Trappers lying in weight and begins
systematically slaughtering them one by
one towards the end of the massacre the
Predator finishes off the last men
standing by leaving behind its Gauntlet
curious the fur Trappers inspect the
device apparently the proper flight
Instinct doesn't quite register in their
brains and they're caught completely off
guard as three drones appear and Target
the poor saps for Destruction
[Music]
the Alien vs Predator films have been
critically panned and are often seen as
a stain on both franchises however there
are still a few great Concepts within
the films as well as Stellar creature
designs and practical effects in fact
one of the Predator's coolest weapons is
actually only seen in Alien vs Predator
Requiem the predator in this film sets
out to clean up aliens running rampant
in rural Colorado with a whip during a
monstrous Clash at the film's climax
this is no ordinary whip however the
entire length of the weapon is laced
with barbs and it seems specifically
designed to combat Xenomorphs
in fact it's very reminiscent of a
xenomorph tale co-director Greg Strauss
confirmed it was actually made from that
very thing so it can withstand acidic
blood and maintain sharpened edges
capable of ripping opponents to shreds
prey manages to breathe fresh life into
the franchise while still feeling every
bit like a predator movie one of the
many ways it does this is by introducing
us to one of the coolest defensive
gadgets ever used by these cunning
Hunters this yaocha has a fancy Shield
tucked away in one of its gauntlets when
engaged by enemy fire it can unfurl The
Shield at a moment's notice it can also
be used offensively after tangling with
a group of fur Trappers the Predator
pins won against a tree in a Chokehold
it activates the shield which emerges
from its Gauntlet and decapitates the
man interestingly enough this Shield has
a rather distinct inspiration as
director Dan Trachtenberg explained to
comicbook.com I teased a while ago that
I took inspiration from the latest God
of War video game and those two things
are in the trailer one is his shield
that you see briefly fans of the popular
2018 video game know that protagonist
Kratos makes use of a slick Shield that
unfolds from a wrist Gauntlet it seems
Trachtenberg is a bit of a gamer and he
found the perfect place to fold the
particular brutality of God of War into
prey
as a hunter any Gadget that can stop its
Target in its tracks would be most
useful enabling the Predator to deliver
a finishing blow with ease one peculiar
weapon in the Predator's Arsenal is the
net gun which can actually be lethal all
on its own depending on the target the
first use of this weapon on screen came
in Predator 2. when the Predator
assaults a cartel in a high-rise
apartment in Los Angeles he uses this
net gun on one of the gang members
the net gun is employed once again in
the first Alien vs Predator film where a
yacha uses it on a xenomorph as the net
constricts around the alien its acidic
blood saves it from Total Annihilation
as it eats away through the net the
alien is then later seen in the film
with a crosshatch scarring on its head
from the weapon prey shows us the
earliest form of this device however
it's not a gun at this stage but simply
a net device that the Predator loves at
its enemies
another staple of the Predator's hunting
Arsenal is the cloaking device which
bends light to give the creature the
effect of being nearly invisible it is
perhaps one of its best tools for
stealthy Maneuvers enabling it to stalk
prey without being seen most Predator
films depict the creature spying on and
stalking its victims before finally
moving in for the kill this wouldn't be
possible without the cloaking technology
affixed to its armor in most cases the
cloaking armor can be disrupted by
debris water impact or perhaps most
memorably blood as hostels engage the
alien Hunter cracks in its cloaking
device become apparent while it's a
useful tool it definitely can be spotted
if a human knows what they're looking
for
still a predator wouldn't exactly be the
alien species we know without the
ability to creep through the trees
almost invisibly one of the most iconic
traits of this Infamous movie monster
the mask is perhaps one of the most
iconic elements of a predator's Arsenal
while the first Predator seen in the
1987 film had a simplistic and smooth
mask by Design Future iterations Would
drastically change providing different
looks for alien hunters aside from just
being a mere accessory The Masks also
Aid the predators in their Hunts by
providing them with distinct visual
capabilities such as thermal imaging and
zoom functionality to Target prey in
most iterations The Mask also contains
the Predator's targeting system for its
shoulder Cannon and other Weaponry in
some cases The Mask itself is armed with
self-defense measures and is capable of
lethal fire as seen in 2018's the
Predator this is demonstrated when young
Rory McKenna takes the alien mask and
goes trick-or-treating with it when one
rude bully decides to throw a can at the
little kid The Mask instantly retaliates
oh
[Music]
the Predator masks seen across the span
of the franchise are wildly varied and
serve several purposes for that reason
they're essential to the Predator's
hunting gear